[Music]
there was one last dirty trick
one last dirty trick before
the big election day in virginia
all right you they've been pushing the
racial stuff the whole time
and they're still pushing the racial
stuff and the final salvo from the
mcauliffe campaign was about how black
kids can't learn from white teachers
it's preposterous this preposterous
argument
but then the final shot
after the charlottesville
hoax the tiki torch guys sent to the
yunkan campaign after the we got to fire
the white teachers
there was someone who showed up at one
of the final yunkan rallies
wearing a
confederate flag on the back of his jean
jacket
wow he's a confederate he's a racist
he's a white now they were smart this
time this guy who the democrats
obviously sent in
at least he wasn't a black guy they did
they made that mistake with the the tiki
torch stunt at the yunkan rally
but they made a few mistakes
the democrats who obviously sent this
guy in made a few mistakes first of all
the the confederate flag that is on the
back of this jean jacket was obviously
just purchased it's brand new it doesn't
have a smudge on it there's no dirt no
lint no wrinkle no rip no nothing they
probably ironed this thing on about an
hour before they sent the person into
the rally the jacket itself might be new
as well now ordinarily when
when someone does a racism
you know there's the racism and then the
trends on the internet what happens
the person who is implicated in the
racism gets doxed their identity is
revealed they're dragged they have to
block their twitter accounts and yet for
this photo
no one seems to have identified who this
person is because this person is wearing
a jean jacket the only thing on the jean
jacket is the confederate flag which was
purchased about three hours prior i
think
collar popped up long hair and a giant
cowboy hat covering up so his identity
is completely concealed you can't look
up who this person is and then if you
look at the thousands and thousands of
people at this yunkan rally
i don't see any confederate flags i
don't see
this is virginia first of all and it's
glenn younkin it's a moderate republican
who's so i don't even think if you're if
if you are the sort
to be interested in in more
racial racially minded sort of
hard-nosed politics i don't think that
you'd be showing up to the glen yunken
rally no one else has anything like that
there's just this one dude
right in front of all the reporters
it's so transparent it's so lame so then
you get these three reporters who just
take the photo of the guy who showed up
in the brand new confederate flag thing
right in front of them
and they push
they push the narrative the completely
false narrative that uh you know young
kittens had
a racist bigot
a supremacist we'll get to that in one
second first though
i've got to tell you about raycon rake i
so loved
my rakons i did i loved them
and i'm speaking in the past tense not
because they broke
not because i got rid of them
because i showed them to my wife
and i shouldn't have done that that was
my fault and then my wife saw them and
she saw the cool case and she saw the
great colors and she saw that they fit
in your ears really really nice and they
don't have little stem sticking out and
she heard that they have extremely high
audio quality and they stay charged for
an extremely long time and you get hours
and hours and hours of listening
now they are her recons they are not
mine
they are hers with eight hours of play
time 32 hours of battery life they are
hers with all those cool colors they are
hers with that built-in mic that allows
her to take phone calls
with the press of a button there hers i
need to get another pair thankfully
though because raycons are so
inexpensive and right now they are
giving you up to 20 off your rake on
order if you go to raycon buy raycon.com
knowles fortunately i can maybe just get
another pair this offer is only
available for a limited time don't miss
it that is by raycon dot com slash
knowles k-w-l-e-s to unlock up to twenty
percent off your raycons by raycon.com
slash
knowles i think my takeaway from this uh
other than the democrats need to get
better at their dirty tricks because
they they used to be a lot better at
these things and now it's pathetic
my big takeaway is there there must not
be a single white supremacist left in
america
i don't i don't think there's a single
one
i mean i guess there's david duke
right and richard spencer maybe who are
almost certainly feds
these guys who like they go there they
go on cnn to play white supremacists on
cnn
and
then can you are there any others
if
if there were white supremacists
racist bigot evil nazi whatever if there
were any of those guys actually in
america
don't you think that democrats could
wrangle one of them and push them toward
going to a glenyonkan rally but they're
going to a glenn young campaign stop
they can't they can't find any of these
guys
so they have to make them up themselves
hold up thank you for watching that
video i'm glad you enjoyed it you can
get more videos like this if you
ring the bell if you subscribe
they still probably won't send you
notifications but you'll at least have a
better chance if you really want to get
updates in the full uncensored show head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you